what is going on there citizens of the reject
nation we are here today to watch the black
adam official trailer numero dos johnny how
are you i am hot and sweaty how are you i
am also sweaty and hot coy how are you hot
and sweaty for some black adam i heard me
bet you are i bet you are i've been studying up
on black adam but this guy he already knows so
much about black adam just the society of america
he knows like everything's gonna happen in this
movie he's gonna predict it all right so you
guys are gonna want to stick around after the
reaction here what he has to say but yeah we're
gonna watch trade for the first time follow koi
zhandro on tick tock 15 seconds 30 seconds to
three minute videos covers i messed it up i messed
up the impressions okay i'm sorry i was impressed
if you wanted like a bite-sized koi impression
that's who i am i like that i glitch in real time
leave a like that'd be very much appreciated
leave a comment let's see what's going on
my son sacrificed his life to save me
these powers are not a gift but a
curse they'll be a gift out of rage
that's cool nice
oh
before innocent people start getting
hurt he's been asleep for 5 000 years
you find us a cell that can hold them we'll
take care of the rest who's on the team oh
passport we don't need passports
we're the justice society holy crap damn
yeah these visuals are top-notch yeah
i'm not peaceful and i never surrender
nor do i surrender
here we
oh yeah go i kneel before no one
you didn't come here to seek
justice you came to exact revenge
you believe you are not worthy
but fate does not make mistakes
you have two paths so much rock walking in slow
motion you can be the destroyer of this world
dude
oh yeah
that was uh excellent excellent trailer i like
that much more than the first one that was my very
first thought was that this is the i wish this
was trailer one yeah halfway through it i was like
this is so much better than that i mean i like the
first trailer but this really felt like something
special you got a lot more of that like emotional
depth with what dwayne johnson has been talking
about that he's gonna bring with black adam and
of course seeing more of the jsa i mean obviously
it's gonna be one of those kids like they didn't
even really show us who the main baddies going to
be in this film but obviously you know it'll be at
a point where it's like okay amanda waller talking
to what looks like formerly the jsa and then is
going to have them go after black adam they're
probably going to team up fight an ultimate baddie
but what i loved about this trailer in particular
was that it did feel pretty much like while you
got all the cool epic visuals which look insane
i was watching this and because of the zack snyder
almost inspiration with the kind of visuals they
do with the fight scenes i was going you know what
it would be cool to watch this guy fight superman
i didn't wear this shirt accidentally today it
looked pretty sweet not gonna lie it looked pretty
awesome and um it looks like he would actually
have a character arc of someone who can find
himself feeling worthy and perhaps do feel like he
can perhaps be a hero instead of just a villainous
path but it does look like a dark brooding
performance what you'd expect don't worry koi
you're going to rock this video i'm just listening
don't worry i'm going to say like three words
i'm listening john take it away i mean
what did you think about the visuals of the
jsa i mean we got to see some cyclone powers
for yeah dude we got to see some cyclone powers
we got to see hawkman like oscillating through
all those different iterations of his weaponry
and stuff like that we got more of dr fate's
abilities and all the prismic sort of force
shields and things he gets to project and
uh yeah this is easily the most enticing
thing i have seen related to black adam what
so like this was the most well-rounded trailer
like you said it looks like there will actually
be some emotional uh heft to some of this and
the visuals look amazing even though we are
seeing a lot of like similar places to what
we've seen in the previous trailers the things
they added to flesh it out did just that for me
and yeah this got me actually excited to see
the movie and excited to see how everybody
at least that they're featuring here interacts
and i like that they learned from the bvs trailer
playbook and they didn't show us the probably
inevitable them all teaming up to fight a bigger
body it's very easy trailer and then all set up
for an actual gsa movie i imagine i believed in
an actual anti-hero situation taking place that
might be a hard one battle that could lead to a uh
you know a face turn yeah yeah face turn good
call all right guys uh i got all right that's it
so for me this did two really important things the
first of which you guys have touched on which is
it's a trailer for a movie that comes out next
month and it didn't give us three minutes of
new footage it gave us maybe a minute and it's
dispersed throughout but it really allowed the
trailer to breathe it gave us more emotion
based off action and i think the best action
is action that has emotion behind it i think a
lot of the times when we look at the greatest
action scenes of all time it's because each punch
lands twice you care about both parties so you're
really invested in the action in a way so i love
that this added emotional half to the actual rdc
that gives us multiple things it gives us lots and
lots of new connective tissue to us to theorize
but it also gives us a bit more mystery when
the movie comes out and has two more hours as
opposed to us piecing together all the things
we've already seen and assembling a movie this
might be just the first two acts it looks like and
i like that we now have a little bit more context
without more footage necessarily but the second
thing this did for me was two things i've always
wanted a sinister six movie that made spider-man
the antagonist i wanted to have a ground level
sinister six where you've got like henchmen
that you're fighting spider-man and then you're
conflicted because everybody loves spider-man how
am i gonna root against spider-man i thought that
was the best way to make a sinister six movie and
the other thing i've always wanted is a justice
league movie that felt like the gods walked among
us that didn't have uh necessarily as much baggage
as you have to do with bunch of movies leading up
but i've always been worried about a team movie to
kick off something i've always been worried that
if you skip a lot of steps this did that for me
we've not met any of these characters yet we're
about to meet hawkman for the first time who's
one of my favorite comic characters aldous hodge
is going to crush it but i'm already invested in
him dr fate cyclone i'm already there and we've
got an atom smasher all of these characters are
many of which predate marvel parallels right so
just because the movies beat them to it doesn't
mean the characters beat them to it and i think
what they're doing is exceptional in showing
the differences in those characters because the
everyday person isn't going to know that dr fate
proceeded doctor strange the average person isn't
gonna recognize that adam smasher is even maybe
different than ant-man people might not realize
these things if you don't read the comic books
so i think they did an exceptional job going like
hey we're skipping ahead to this point but these
are the differences in our characters that scene
of black adam fighting dr fate feels like a panel
from a comic book and it's doing it without
feeling like they rushed to me now obviously
we haven't seen much more than this but everything
feels like it's got more weight and it feels more
earned than i would have expected and it gives us
that sinister sixth thing where you're invested in
both sides of it you're invested in your anti-hero
in this case as well as your team and that's
genius who do you think this this villain is
this red guy this red guy villain who because
this looks like this is probably the main bat yeah
that's three frames or whatever and uh like looks
satanic like imagery look at that star literally
it looks like the devil come to life i mean when i
was researching this movie i was hearing rumors
about the possibility of ishmael showing up in
here so i was looking them up and it kind of looks
like one of the virgins i've seen of ishmael yeah
ishmael doesn't always look like that sometimes he
looks more human but there is a new earth version
that is very much this iconography but he's more
tied to batman and the lazarus pit that also might
be trigon who's tied to like the new teeton titans
and raven's death and if i'm not mistaken hawkman
is a character who is a descendant of someone
from like black adam's time and so i imagine
that this villain himself is throughout time and
like that's the thing they've been yeah perhaps
or another descendant or something like
that but probably linked to the pharaoh
who ultimately um wanted to kill black adam at the
very top of this movie and that's another thing
that i'm liking about what this trail is doing
because he does look very much anguished and very
much full of rage and they have these like human
characters i noticed who have like nothing to do
with anybody else here i think that seems like the
eye lines there are like i understand because this
guy's from like thanagar so they're gonna have to
explain the thanagarians aloud to the audience and
i think they're gonna be the people they expand
that to like there's gonna have to be those
characters that are like excuse me what's going on
that's all yeah and they're also but it also will
allow for um black adam to possibly learn a little
bit about the good better side of humanity because
looks like when he's awakened you know i like
that line about he says i'm like the magic magic
is weak yeah yeah like talking about the bullets
and then there might be some of that humor that
a little bit that fish out of water quality with
a person who is you know a person out of time and
like oh what is what is modern day like which i'm
sure rock can do comedy we know that it's gonna be
fun to play with shazam too because it had a lot
of that fish out of water but with the age thing
right like they were able to and these eventually
we hope to see these two conflict because it is
one continuity we've teased black adam shazam so
i'm really excited for like those disparate fish
out of water stories to kind of come together this
looks incredible the visuals are insane i got like
that's usually like a really easy thing to say but
in a day and age where you know we're hearing all
this talk about visual effects departments
getting pissed off at studios and feeling
like they're under crunch time and pressure you
know which studio i'm referring to right now but
we hear that talk all the time that it is kind of
refreshing in a weird way to say because before
that's what you always used to lean on and now
it's refreshing again to be like wow look how
insanely great these visuals actually look it's
a it's a visual feast to behold uh so yeah it
looks like imax i'm ready for i met this looks
like i want to see it as big as possible which
is another catchphrase but in this case it looks
needed all right guys well follow coy on tick tock
also last thing pierce brosnan's lag full effect
i just want to give credit it's important when he
transforms out of doctor fate and just that walk
gold charisma that's why he cast pierce brosnan
swag swag i mean now this hodge looks great who's
playing cyclone i forget her name cause i'm a
monster we're not getting enough we didn't get
much of her here we said we hadn't gotten a lot
of her in general uh she was great at the panel
at comic-con because her and adam spatcher who
asked forget the name of it centennial thank you
noah centennial they had this we know all the men
they had this really incredible bond where they
talked about how cool it felt to play young heroes
together and how the two of them like kind of went
through like superhero training together and there
was like this bond of team because of that and it
was really special to see everyone in that stage
feel like a family and this is the first movie
sometimes that takes sequels and everything to
build up to and and they were just really great on
on stage together yeah i completely agree i love
noah's antonio i've said it many times i'm one of
those people who's in love with that man ready for
elder assad to be a household name he has earned
it ten times definitely fantastic amazing act very
underrated under under recognize that
and whenever he's in some people we're
like albus watch is great i'm like this
guy should be more famous good he is like
he's an amazing amazing talent of an actor he does
lines that like shouldn't work an invisible man
throughout like there's so much dialogue i'm
like only aldous hodge and i can't wait to see
that in the superhero scale i love that amanda
wall that was like the connective thread yeah
i absolutely love it she's gonna bring henry
cavill back only amanda waller in character i hope
so i bet it's a post-credits scene cam it's gotta
be it's gotta be all right guys well what did you
think about this trailer leave your thoughts down
below like i said uh two minutes ago follow koi
on uh tick tock you can subscribe to us but
let's not end this video without doing a p
gabriel gabriel now gabriel i know we talked
about your name before but i'm gonna look up what
gabriel means on urban dictionary today gabriel
now i don't know if you're a guy or a girl your uh
profile photo doesn't tell us but it says the type
of guy who can make you laugh but has that serious
side of him ooh oh you got duality oh you're like
you're you're like me gabriel like i'm hilarious
but a violent monster on the inside just like
you yeah he gets what he wants when he wants it
oh you are just as abusive as me that's good
to know we need to abuse our way to the top
and don't get me started on his dimples
gabriel's got great dimples you can sit
from a mile away that's what people always say
about my dimples too you and i have the dimps
he tends to be kind of quiet but only when he
is making a dirty plan we're perverts gabriel
never trust a silent name he never trusts us
pervs but he has a side where he can think of him
as a brother that's true we are perverted with
our brothers and you never want to hurt him no
because we will abuse you with our pervertedness
yeah gabriel's a perverted abuser here you can
tell you can tell gabriel whatever and he'll
listen and if he likes you enough he'll tell
you stuff about him he wouldn't even tell his mom
yeah like all the dastardly abuses he's committed
that's great oh my god gabriel i hope you can
confide in me considering we have so much in
common the secret of the dimps we are just as
good and just as awful simultaneous there's
nothing really awful here about gabriel that we
know of however uh i i think that you and i both
know we got some dark deeds within us no we're
both little devils on the inside ambish impish
gabriel sexy gabriel thank you unless you're
a woman you are lovely to be around gabrielle